thank you
[Music]
questions
here we go
[Music]
foreign
good evening welcome to the table
good to see you guys tonight so we
clearly have a completely different
thing going on
I don't know if you could tell
it's hiding behind me
we'll get to that in a second my name is
Don Jacobs welcome to the table glad
that you guys are here those of you who
are joining us online we are thrilled
that you are joining us as well so um
yeah so if this is a baptism Sunday
um yeah it's exciting about that this
looks amazing by the way
um I love this little symbol going on
here and I don't know where to stand
correctly up here anyway
so yeah in the water probably not a good
idea
but I'm sorry yeah so just thank you for
friends and family who were able to
um join in and participate
um they're for those of us who are those
of you guys who are getting baptized so
we're looking forward to that near the
end of the service
um and the other thing I want to mention
to you guys
um is that I want to recognize those
individuals who help work with setup and
tear down these are the people that set
up things before service
[Applause]
and they stay later in all the things
that just make things work if you've
participated in that do you mind raising
your hand real quick so just we just
want to see
[Music]
[Applause]
so anyway thank you guys so much for
that so with that being said we'll get
started here with service I want to lead
us quickly in a prayer
Laura thank you so much for bringing us
here together thank you for this evening
thank you for the support of family and
friends and just to be seen
I pray you just open our hearts and
Minds to what is going to be shared
tonight
in Christ's name I pray amen
amen
all right will you guys stand up with us
we are going to get started with some
songs
and this first song is called free amen
and I just feel like it is such an
appropriate one to kick off baptism
Sunday because we all need some more
freedom in our lives and I'm so proud of
you guys who are making an active
untangible way of walking towards that
freedom so let's get going
two three
amen
[Music]
amen now you know what sing it along
with us
[Music]
amen
everybody sing yes
[Music]
amen
oh falling down my play love that I
can't explain the peace that steals my
soul
the light in the darkest place
[Music]
there is
with the blood of Christ
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies
there is
[Applause]
[Music]
Almighty my everything
[Applause]
[Music]
the Lord is there
there is freedom
I am free amen yes
[Music]
[Applause]
thank God
[Music]
[Applause]
awesome
all right you kids are dismissed to your
classes please go through the front
rooms up here at the front of the room
the doors I mean in the front of the
room and just for you parents to be
aware tonight because it's baptism
Sunday
um when we get to that part of the
service where the baptisms are happening
we would love for our kids to be a part
of that and get to see that part of the
service and be fully included
um so we are going to have the kids come
back in for the baptisms and they will
rejoin you in your seats so um they
won't stay with their kids workers at
that point they'll come and sit with you
so just be ready to receive them back
when we get to the baptisms
um and we're going to move into prayers
of the people
um
and I just invite anyone who's joining
us online to feel free to leave a
comment
um of what you're carrying on your heart
so that we can share that with those of
us here in the room
would you guys read this prayer aloud
with me
for this city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth you have given us and the wisdom
and the will to conserve it we pray to
you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and the orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental health and emotional health
we pray to you Lord we know that you
love us and that you hear us so we lift
these names and situations up to you
[Music]
foreign
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that
we've kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light healing and hope peace and a
deep sense of your presence amen
foreign
[Music]
it's all the Lost alone
to all the thieves will come confessed
I know that you are holy
[Music]
and know that you are holy
and all will sing out
Hallelujah
and we will cry out Hallelujah
[Music]
thank you
I know that you are holy
and always
[Music]
[Applause]
shout out
to go on and scream it from the
mountains
go on and tell it to the
masses
that he is
[Music]
[Applause]
go on and scream it from the mountains
[Music]
that he
is
[Applause]
[Music]
don't cry
go on and tell me
[Music]
go on and scream it from the mouth
that he
is God one more time
[Music]
go on and screaming
mountains
go on and tell it to the Man
says
that he is
please
[Music]
the Lord bless you
the end keep you
make his face shine upon you be gracious
to you
Lord turn his
face toward you
then give you peace
[Music]
[Applause]
amen
[Music]
his face shine upon you and be gracious
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
a
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
the children
[Applause]
he's with you he's with you in the
morning
[Music]
and rejoice
I
love me
[Music]
[Applause]
sing that out amen
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
please
your clothes
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
man
uh
[Music]
Jesus thank you that you are for us
you are with us
you never leave us
you don't forsake us
you do a good work in our hearts God and
you carry it out to completion
you see the good thing that you've
started
and you call it forward
you are our hope you are our light
you are our guide
would we anchor ourself into you
would you be our Solid Rock when
everything else is sinking stand
would you be our foundation
when our world is crumbling
you hold all things together
God would we sink ourselves into these
truths
would our lives be patterned and shaped
by them
would we follow you into new territory
into New Seasons
and God would we have hope for the
future
a hope that does not disappoint
thank you that you make room for all of
it our whole story God
the bumps the bruises the chaos
the crumble
but that you are also rebuilding
and renewing and redeeming
would we make space for that God
would we have faith to believe it and to
follow it to walk after it
thank you for the kind of God that you
are
would we come to know that Jesus
would we come to trust that Jesus
we love you and we celebrate what you're
doing here we celebrate these people who
are taking the next step towards you
towards all that you have for them
it's in your name that we pray amen
eight well Grace and peace
it is so good to be with all of you my
name is Brett I'm the pastor here at the
table and
um
and yeah it's just it's wonderful to to
see you all and I see a lot of familiar
faces I see a lot of new faces and uh
and some faces that I just haven't seen
in a while but it's wonderful to see you
again and so I just I'm so grateful to
to be here with with all of you and as
always that includes those joining us
online love you all lots and um and
especially anyone here who's new thank
you for uh for being with us so uh as
you you all know
it is the baptism Sunday and I was I
want to um take some time to just unpack
what baptism is although I realize when
I say it like that it uh well it sounds
a little bit silly because like any um
well baptism is the is what's known as a
Sacrament a a means of divine or God's
grace in our lives like uh like you
imagine like a river or a Channel of
God's grace and of course Christ is
always present to us but there's like
certain moments certain practices where
it's like heaven touches Earth you know
like we um normally won't do it tonight
but almost every Sunday we practice
um communion and come forward that's
like a Sacramento a moment of divine
grace and the thing about uh a Sacrament
is of course saying like well this is
what it means
you know is always like well falling
short
um because it doesn't mean like a thing
you know or two things
um it's sort of like if I it's people do
this sometimes with um art
uh you know where they'll be like what
does that painting mean
it's like uh well it's not really that
sort of thing right where it means like
oh this this is what it means you know
um it's there's always an excess of
meaning you know the same with like
poetry what does that point mean well
it's not a thing if there's always an
excess of me or what is your your
marriage what does that mean or your
closest friendship what does that mean
you know it's like well my goodness
that's uh that's a big statement uh so
the truth is of course it's it's always
um an excessive meaning always
um and in essence baptism like will go
on discovering what that means like our
entire life
um now having said that I do still want
to attempt to unpack some of what
baptism means and I'll be a hypocrite
and go back on everything I said and uh
try to explain it as best as best I can
so the the title of um the message
tonight is baptism and freedom baptism
and freedom and we're going to be drawn
from Romans 6 throughout the the message
so let's Jump Right In so the first
thing that that baptism frees us from is
the compulsive or I almost put um
addictive nature of sin uh Romans
chapter 6 verses one through three the
Apostle Paul writes these words he says
what shall we say then
shall we go on sinning so that Grace may
increase by no means we are those who
have what
died to sin how can we live in it any
longer or don't you know that all of us
who were baptized into Christ Jesus were
baptized into his death in other words
identified with Christ in his death uh
you know I know not everyone in like the
the modern world
believes in in like the Demonic and such
dark evil forces
um I do but and I think most Christians
do but you know not if you go out of
these walls and not everyone believes in
such things but it's interesting
um that even like the most you know
secular of of people
uh tends to kind of think of their life
in in almost um kind of imaginative
terms as like moving either constantly
upward
or downward
uh not literally right like oh I'm
flying not that but like in in the sense
of um moving upward towards their like
highest ideals and values and calling I
mean even the obsession with like what's
my purpose you know like there's just
this sense of I like what are they
oriented towards like it's almost as
though uh someone
God is calling them drawing them towards
Beauty and goodness and love and and
people have this innate sense even if
they're not Christians or anything like
have this sense of like I've got to
become something you know I've got to
grow into something uh that like the the
best version of me even if that's kind
of secular clunky language to use in a
church setting I get but like you you
see where people have this understanding
right there's something deep within or
something outside US calling us drawing
us upward you might say
however
there is also something at times it
feels within sometimes outside us that
is doing what
calling us drawing us where
downward
it's like the it's the opposite of the
upward movement right and and everything
the upward movement kind of symbolizes
it's like downward towards what well
that's what the Bible calls sin but it's
it's the stuff we're very familiar with
it's like those old compulsions and
addictions and fears oh that's a big one
in our lives isn't it and
um this uh our conflict with one another
and our rivalries and our suspicions and
our and our greeds and our crave it's
like oh my gosh and and sometimes we
experience that downward pull like so
powerfully that it feels inevitable have
you ever been there where it just it's
like such a I mean especially if you've
ever struggled with any sort of
addiction
let's be honest we're in the modern
world pretty much all of us have
struggled with some sort of addiction
and it is I mean it's powerful right
it's like oh my gosh I feel like I can't
stop myself right
now the good news
the Gospel of Jesus Christ
is that
once you are in alignment with him
that there is nothing within you or
outside you
that can compel you force you drag you
downward again in other words by God's
grace we are free
to begin to move forward and to go back
to my previous metaphor where
upward
upward towards the God who is father-son
Spirit towards love in community and
connection in the person that God's
calling us to be friends that is freedom
that is freedom and that's the the
freedom that Christ purchased on the
cross and it's the freedom that those
who are going to be baptized today uh
step into and begin to realize in their
lives now of course I said we are free
to begin to live and choose differently
right because it's not like a foregone
conclusion
um that oh so automatically you go into
those baptismal Waters and you're free
at last and we're like all the song you
know like yay and everything's great
forever in my life um not necessarily
right but it's now I've got the spirit
of God within me and there's a power
greater within me and by God's grace I
can choose differently and friends
sometimes that makes all the difference
just knowing I can I'm not forced
compelled so that's number one baptism
frees us from the compulsive nature of
sin number two baptism frees us from the
fear of death
I remember I was about uh 10 years old
or so and we my family night was like
holiday season we went down to this old
downtown Plano like where the DART
station is now at 15th uh Street and
um it might have been before the DART
station was there I can't recall I'm old
okay I don't know I guess that's all
relative you know it's just the high
schoolers
say yeah he's old you know for sure
um but so there we were but I remember
it was like it's where that um that old
there's like that beautiful church right
down there if you've ever been in that
area I think it's maybe Disciples of
Christ Church but anyway it's just a
beautiful church and I remember like
holiday season lights of course it was
like night time it was beautiful and I
just it's one of those weird memories
where I can't I don't know all the
context because it was so long ago when
I was so young but I remember is we were
sitting as a family sitting on a bench
right outside that church
and it was beautiful
and the like Christmas carols were
playing I mean it was just a idyllic
like wonderful moment and suddenly maybe
at that point probably for the first
time in my life I had like this thought
just entered my mind and like gripped me
and the thought was I am going to die
I know I was a weird kid
I was like that kid from What About Bob
if y'all sleep I know it's an old movie
but uh you know that kid was just
obsessed with this existential angst
about I am going to die everyone I love
right it's just this now uh we laugh now
but like back then I'll tell you it was
no laughing matter in that moment like
it was weird because it wasn't a sad
moment you know I mean it was it wasn't
like oh my gosh like everything was
going wrong in my life and then I
realized you know
no it was like everything was it was
almost as though
the goodness of that moment
the beauty of that moment
suddenly drove home the opposite point
right that like I knew it wouldn't last
like like suddenly it was probably for
the first time in my life I actually
became afraid of death and I think the
older we get the more this
um point this point is pressed home for
us like if you're younger you know I
think as I recall teen years it was easy
to forget this my early 20s I could kind
of pretend that I was going to be
immortal uh but it just isn't so and at
some point from at least for me it was
like mid to late 20s suddenly
it hit me like for real not in a
fleeting one moment but like in an
ongoing way for some of us it's like the
first gray hair or a chronic illness or
something where we have to face our
mortality
right and it hits us and for some of us
like it hits Us in the face it's like a
rude awakening
and and this this causes tremendous fear
in what happens often is that it comes
out sideways in us like it comes out in
this kind of grasping at life and people
and experiences and it's like we're
trying kind of desperately to get it all
have it all hang on to it all while we
can and what's what's underneath that
right at the surface you wouldn't
necessarily know what's going on but
what's underneath it there's like a deep
fear in us it's a fear of death and it
looms very large for us but here is the
good news as Christians we no longer
have to be afraid of death Romans
chapter 6 verse 3 says or don't you know
that all
ah baptized into Christ Jesus were
baptized into his death which sounds
like very bad news you know it's like oh
gosh I don't know I want that uh
baptized into his death first four we
were therefore buried with him through
baptism into death in order that what
just as Christ was raised from the dead
through the glory of the father we too
may live a new life for we have been
United with him in a death like his we
will certainly also be United with him
in a resurrection like his and if you
think of the imagery of baptism it is
exactly that passage we go under the
waters
and it's a picture of what
of that death
and we're joined with Christ in the
grave in the Tomb
and then what we are raised to New Life
like this is the good news we don't have
to be afraid I mean the worst that
happens is that we die
and we go to be with Christ like The God
Who is father-son Spirit the loving
relationship itself
uh gave you might say I'm created each
and every one of us
and we are in Christ joined back with
him and so we don't have to live in fear
any longer but we can have tremendous
hope
that the God who raised his servant and
son Jesus Christ from the dead
the father will also raise us so baptism
frees us from the fear of death third
and finally baptism frees us from an ego
driven identity Romans 6 verse 6 again
for we know that our old self
was crucified with him so that the body
ruled by sin might be done away with
that we should no longer be slaves to
sin that last line you can kind of hear
Echoes of Point number one about that
compuls kind of compulsive addictive
nature of sin I want to focus in on the
first part though that language of old
self for we know that our old self was
crucified with him this is what else
where Paul calls the flesh by which he
doesn't simply mean like just you know
that body however at least as we all
commonly understand the body
um he really means it's that that old um
that part of us
that is constantly insecure
and Afraid and grasping and attempting
to like build a self and identity apart
from The God Who is the father-son
spirit like it's it's a it's a sense of
um
yeah us it's an identity thing and it's
it's the way we often build that
identity on rather shallow uh things for
example uh clothes
or our job or a car or house or a friend
group or our marital status or our
education level or our bank account or
ideas of success or being accepted and
approved of by others that's a powerful
one in our lives isn't it like I am
valuable
because they love me
right I am worthy and a somebody
because
so and so chose me right and you can
actually this becomes a real problem
pastors do this with their congregations
it actually becomes a real problem as
you can imagine it's like I'm worthy as
long as you all like me it's like oh
gosh heading for trouble here all right
but this is what we do and you can see
how this is a very precarious Foundation
upon which to build a self
a sense of self because what happens
when they don't
right or what happens when that career
goes away what happens when the the
children that you kind of built your
life on like and they're good kids my
kids are good kids and what happens if
they're suddenly not so good anymore
my daughter Eve's in here I know you'll
always be good so this isn't not
questioning that but just there
critically what right and you can see
where all of a sudden it's like the very
it's like the ground gives way beneath
us
we say things like I don't even know who
I am any more
what is it that's that it's building a
life on our old self it's sort of like
the the Tower of Babel you might think
we're building a self
by Brick by Brick with all of these
things but the truth is it does not work
we remain insecure and Afraid which begs
the question what is the only secure
place to stand what is the only
foundation upon which to build our true
identity our true self
our baptism
if you recall the moment that Christ
himself which it's remarkable to
consider that Jesus himself was baptized
you remember when Christ himself was
baptized
right before he went under those Waters
and this was in his life this was before
he had preached a sermon or healed
people
spoke an amazing prophetic words he
hadn't done anything just living normal
life and do you remember the voice of
the one he called Abba Father do you
remember what that voice said
this is my what beloved Son in whom I am
well pleased
and when you go under those Waters God
speaks the exact same word over you this
is my beloved Son my daughter my child
in whom I am well pleased and that
becomes a firm foundation upon which to
build a life because I'll tell you that
love never goes away
and that love comes from the very one
who knows you and made you
so we've got to begin to stand in that
new identity
and there's a freedom with that we
become freed from the need for that old
ego driven
um awesome because I'm educated you know
or I make whatever number of dollars a
year you know all these weird ways we as
Americans try to secure our sense of
self instead we just come back to our
baptism
as God speaks that same word over us
beloved
beautiful Worthy
forgiven
accepted
baptism frees us from our ego driven
we all bow your heads and close your
eyes
I want to pray this over us
Lord Jesus
for those of us who have been baptized
we remember again our calling Our Hope
and our freedom
and we celebrate those today who are
either renewing or making their first
baptismal plunge beneath these holy
Waters may they too walk in Resurrection
Life may they too walk in your great
freedom
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit
amen
so we are going to start transitioning
into baptisms so if someone wants to
get the kiddos let them let them know
um we're gonna yeah in just a minute
we'll we'll start this so I have this
this um
this piece let me go ahead and read this
our Lord Jesus Christ
who has told us
that to enter the kingdom of heaven we
must be born again of water and of the
spirit the same Christ has given us
baptism as the sign in the Seal of this
new birth
here in these Waters
we are Washed by the Holy Spirit and we
are made clean here we are clothed with
Christ
dying to sin that we may live his risen
life as children of God we have a new
dignity and God calls us to fullness of
life
all right
kiddos thanks for being in here
hey
so uh
we're gonna baptize some people
uh the first person I want to invite up
is Brandon Randall
give him a hand as he comes forward
stand here
all right there we go so Brandon how
about you uh go ahead and share with
everyone a little bit of the story of
why you would like to be baptized today
wrote a few things down
so I've been a Believer basically my
whole life grew up in church and I was
baptized by immersion just like this in
the first grade and the foundation of my
faith hasn't changed but a lot of other
things have and I mean I'm not sure
about y'all but I can't even remember
the first grade much less telling you
about my faith in Jesus back then but I
was baptized yes and still baptism is
only a symbol of faith that didn't save
me but for the past few years I've
really felt the need to be baptized
again and when considering why two words
come to mind responsibility and
accountability they go together I have
many responsibilities now that I intend
to carry out as Brett mentioned none of
these Define me but I want to live the
let Christ shine through these
responsibilities
um a loving husband a kind father at
work a project manager at church a small
group leader and Tech volunteer I want
Christ to use me and these
responsibilities to glorify him
and to allow me to point others to him
and then accountability baptism is a
public Declaration of Faith it's public
because we are all one body of Christ
I'm getting baptized to say to all of
you that I want to live in Christ as
Christ lived to be to be vulnerable
hospitable honest and kind and I know
that I will fail and that's why I'm here
in a community to have community and
accountability there
I'm getting baptized here knowing that
you the community will lift me up when I
struggle to live out these words as you
all already have so many times
wonderful
all right I'm gonna step on in
yeah go ahead and sit down
it should be nice and warm is it pretty
good decent all right that's good
go ahead and yeah hold your nose and
then hold right there there you go
before about uh Brandon do you repent of
the sins that separate you from God and
from neighbor I do
you turn to Christ as Savior I do do you
submit to Christ as Lord I do
and Brandon I baptize you in the name of
the Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
thank you
Jeremiah Parker come on forward my
friend
[Music]
definitely yeah
that's the the moment of truth
awesome all right
yeah maybe this is better if I stand up
here and then we're almost equal yeah
um Jeremiah can you go ahead and share
it with everyone uh just the story of
some of why you want to be baptized
today
um Mike
um
I want to be baptized because for most
of my life I was a vehement annoying
flagrant atheist and it took they can
hear me and as of recently
um I've decided that I don't want to be
that anymore and that I believe in God
now I believe in the father and the Son
and the Holy Spirit and I want to walk
in newness of life with Christ
it's awesome that's sufficient that's
great that's great
[Applause]
all right step on in
and
Hayden is gonna go ahead and do some
baptizing so here step on in German
sorry
[Music]
all right you can go ahead and sit down
Jeremiah
take the plunge Jeremiah
do you repent of the sins that separate
you from God and from neighbor obviously
dude
do you learn humility and Grace
and
do you turn to Christ as Savior yes do
you submit to Christ as Lord yes
baptize you in the name of the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit
[Applause]
thank you
proud of you buddy
all right
we did get permission from Pleasant
Valley before baptizing in their
sanctuary
they're more of the sprinkling
congregation you know so we're like can
we uh go hardcore in here so um Eden
come on up my friend
can you stand up here okay
go ahead and share with everyone that a
little bit of the story of why you want
to be baptized today
I'm gonna try to do this without crying
um
okay
so
um I didn't write out a full-on script
so I'm just kind of winging it um but I
did write down some notes so I did grow
up in the face
um and
Jesus always meant a lot to me
throughout my whole life
um and then oh I'm sorry
um
and then I realized that I liked girls
and I had grown up as a girl and
um this was like a really big turning
point for me because I didn't know
there were so many different
um opposing views that were tugging at
my heart
um but I knew
um I knew myself and I knew that God
loved me and
so that was really important to me
um and then
I officially like gave my life to Christ
over the covid years and actually uh
felt so compelled as to start like a
mini devotional page on my Instagram
um and that's where I really love to
spread the word of God
um and then
another
queer curveball came at me
um when I realized that I'm trans
and that um
slowly transitioning and becoming who I
am today has been a long process but
sharing the gospel has always been a
part of that and I just want to reaffirm
and strengthen
uh who I am now and really commit my
life to Christ and I feel my calling is
um
to live my life as God wanted me or as
God has wanted me to live my life and
that is to create an example for other
um
people that have felt separated from the
church and that you can
you can get back and feel loved and
accepted so
[Applause]
sit down
there you go my friend
it's pretty low
Eden do you repent of the sins that
separate us from God and from neighbor
yeah
do you turn to Christ as Savior yeah
do you submit to Christ as Lord yes
Eden
I baptize you in the name of the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit
foreign
[Applause]
you give him another hand
uh
uh it's a beautiful thing
isn't it it's beautiful to see that that
New Freedom
happening in people's life and uh man I
couldn't have imagined three years ago
when we started this community just what
God would do Among Us and uh so much
Beauty so much Beauty and people finding
hope in life and love and at the end of
the day Christ Jesus Christ who saves so
yeah I'm grateful and grateful for
Jeremiah and Brandon and Eden uh
grateful for each of you all right if
you join me in a in a prayer Lord God
we
feel this time
this holy moment
where Heaven has touched Earth
where people have stepped into new
levels
of faithfulness to you
of turning away from sin and struggle
and moving towards life in light and
hope and peace
towards you Christ
towards a relationship with you
connection with you
and may they become faithful followers
of you
so we give you this time
we give you Eden
Brandon Jeremiah
the work that you've begun in their
hearts would it go deep into them
in the name of Jesus Christ I pray
amen
you guys want to stand with us and let's
sing this blessing over
especially bring it in Eden and Jeremiah
but over our own lives and our community
and this city
[Music]
Mia's presence may his business go
before you and behind you and beside you
all around you everything
[Music]
let's sing that one more time May's
presence go before you and behind you
and beside you all around you anything
you he's with you he is with you in the
morning and the evening
[Music]
are you he's for you
[Applause]
one more time
[Music]
um
still not sure where to stand
it's amazing
um I just want to say real quick before
we get dismissed how much of a privilege
it was to witness
um this this was
by the way don't ever apologize for
grabbing this microphones or crying
but it is a blessing to be in you guys's
presence so thank you thank you so much
as you guys are
um we're about to dismiss and everything
like that just want to do a couple
reminders if you were visiting thank you
so much for being here we do have
um some cards in the way back as you
kind of walk out that door there's a
table on the right side if you wouldn't
mind just kind of filling out one of
those poor s and stick it in there's a
box outside out there just so that we
just have a record of your visit also if
you feel so inclined and you would like
to continue to support this ministry uh
you can just do so online also you can
make your donation in that box as well
if you need some
to be seen feed a handshake a hug a high
five or something as you're walking out
that door I'll be sitting back there for
you guys for that
and as we get ready to dismiss I want to
send you out in this with this
benediction
so you or a child of God
you are a child of God
and this is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
the Seattle determine highs and lows and
everything in between go filled with the
assurance that you are loved you are
worthy and you are accepted Just As You
Are
and go filled with God's gifts God's
Holy Spirit and the desire to extend
these same Gifts of Grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
in contact with
thank you have a good evening
please
[Music]
foreign
ah man
[Music]